COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
we help some ML video experts
with their download speeds.
Will we hit the target bitrate?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Video Miner is a video
processing and ML company.
And they came to
me with an issue.
It was taking about
two minutes to transfer
a video from cloud
storage to a VM,
where computation could occur.
Now 120 seconds may not
sound like a long time
to transfer a 4-gig video.
But when you're paying for the
CPU while that's downloading,
it feels like an eternity.
Worse off is that one
of their engineers
was reporting that curl
was out performing gsutil
for the downloads, which
didn't sound right to me.
So of course, I wanted to
see the problem myself.
So I set up a small test
that downloaded videos
of different sizes from a
cloud storage bucket to a VM
in US Central 1 and
actually confirmed
their performance findings.
Asking around, it seemed
as though the challenge
with gsutil is that the
default settings don't line up
well for large file downloads.
By default, gsutil will spread
downloads across four threads,
but only use one process.
For copying a single
file on a powerful VM,
we can improve that
performance by limiting
the number of threads,
forcing the system
to use multiple
processes instead.
To do this, we can specify
a command line option
to reduce the thread count to 1.
Now, with this small change,
we improve the performance,
but we're still not at the
level that curl is showing
when fetching through HTTP.
So for large files, there's a
nifty feature in gsutil that
should help us out a bit more.
Gsutil uses HTTP
range get requests
to perform sliced
downloads in parallel when
downloading large objects
from Google Cloud Storage.
Along with setting
the thread count to 1,
we will also set the number
of max components to 8.
This gives us a much
improved per download speed.
So if you're interested in
using either of these flags
to improve
performance, check out
the article linked in
the description below.
And don't forget to check out
the rest of Cloud Performance
Atlas content.
Because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]